Seth what were you 10 years ago
religious spent a lot of time in the
mosque was celibate didn't drink would
you tell 19-year old Johnny to not die
sir this is the question that the
Internet is tuned in to here by Bitcoin
by Facebook by Netflix by Amazon and
don't bother with you you need to stop
drinking and focus on personal
development you need to focus on
yourself first and not on other people
you don't know as much as you think you
do stop getting into relationships with
girls that are bad for you no I really
mean it stop getting into relationships
with girls that are bad for you you
think you know it all don't it when
you're 19 you think you've got to figure
it out you haven't gotten clue until
you're at least 28 and I would say
probably 39 year old me without saying
the same thing I can tell you the
equivalent of mate you're gonna get hit
by a car in ten years time and you won't
believe it until you get hit by the car
wherever you are giving people the most
advice it's probably where you need the
advice the most all this stuff that
we've just said is all advice that we
all need right now
Podcast time ladies and gentlemen
welcome back I'm joined by Gianni and
Yusuf from propane fitness Kalyani and
Yousuf Yousuf from Johnny I'm Johnny and
Johnny from you so you said you see if
it's got rid of the moustache she's back
now with a beard
it's about 11s so much better les pido e
what does she think mention that and
mean your last one cuz my ah yeah well
play the podcast game of time yeah
anyway today we are talking about advice
that we would give ourselves 10 years
ago
pretty good opportunity for us to just
unload all of the [ __ ] that we've
learned over the last 10 years but we're
gonna try and keep it to within an hour
so hopefully be nice and condensed maybe
you can take some wisdom away that we've
gleaned hard-earned wisdom over the last
few years through blood and sweat and
tears and feces our loss is your gain
that's a really good tagline for a
product hmm of some kind like a hair
loss product or something that'd be your
loss is our gain
well yeah which is a bit insidious
because if you lose you were havin we're
out of the snow business a person will
actually know because in that instance
we're getting too much into it anyway so
let's let's do some framing Johnny what
sort of a person weed how old were you
what sort of person we 10 years ago I
was
maths time I was 19 very blonde yeah da
ba hey blonde at times was it highlights
or was it fully dyed full head oh hello
I think is the only facebook status I
remember you posting us just as like a
stasis it was quoting your dad oh yeah
said that I mean I'm not gonna do it so
yeah no no because yeah the start the
podcast again yeah but it was a
derogatory about hack made of our Johnny
I was probably quite so I think the
thing that I would tell 19-year old
Johnny and properly 20 year old 21 year
old 22 probably up Tyler we're getting
into it or early twenty seven well it's
just because this is the theme like you
think you know it all don't it when
you're 19 you think you've got to figure
it out you're like yeah I have been
through my teens now another crack
another score
under the seed you haven't got a [ __ ]
clue until you at least 28 27 and I
would say probably 39 year old me it's
gonna think was I saying the same thing
and that probably like yeah huge thing
your entire twenties are just this one
big realization that nothing's
unbelievable and if you don't you're
just fumbling around in a dark room yeah
I'm trying to find a light what you're
looking what's that I can't use that
what's our date yeah okay so let's take
it from the top
would you tell 19-year old Johnny to not
dice her this question this is the
question that the Internet is tuned in
to here hmm that's why everyone's here
yes all these people here
that's why they're in in there I think I
think you have to do things to learn why
so like I had told myself not to and I
wouldn't have listened to me maybe I
would listen to me I think you also
don't want to be one of those people who
at the age of 40 never dyed the hair
when they were 18 midlife crisis so
what's what what happened was I finished
school I went on a holiday like the
holiday a lot people go on the finish
school broke up with the girlfriend I
was with at the time I was just about to
go uni I had all this like really long
summer ahead of me I was like you know
what bollocks I'm gonna dye my hair I'm
gonna become a guy that has blond yeah I
was I was gonna become this like
different person and I think going into
uni it did a lot for my confidence I
can't place why but at the time like now
would be really weird like I think
no-one does happen at the time loads of
people were see I probably would do it
again go
so what else what else were you what was
what what was your I was about entities
about 77 kilos okay yeah that's that's a
lot of weight gain I've gone it was yeah
I've gone from them two kilos a year
over 10 years yeah yeah yeah yeah
is that right actually yeah yeah
probably around 80 kilos
right yeah I remember end of school you
went up to was it he was in stone at the
time so I think he kissed a hundred
posts holiday no no down that and then
almost right but I'd been at uni for a
bit okay anyway yeah we go in the weeds
so yet just come out of like doing a lot
of running so I did a lot of running
when I was that age like legs yeah I was
good at running actually probably
thought I was just gonna follow a
traditional pastor propene didn't exist
then 2008 yeah it was the also did the
the outline of it existed by thought it
was like there's no way I'll ever do
that as a more than it more than a joke
I was studying economics probably pretty
boring bursting to get uni and just blow
that loose just give the tubes are good
in the pile evening leo just all pipes
okay yeah really getting in all right so
that's where you were 10 years ago
yes F what were you 10 years ago so I'm
looking forward to yeah there's a lot of
differences so I think just going back
one year more so yep just before 18th
birthday was 59 kilos what do I know
went up so over a three months I gained
30 kilos went up to 90 thinking it was
all muscle over three months it was
three probably three to six months when
I was doing my pure mud pile of double
cream before bed shots of olive oil
throughout the day Newton Mass had
consumed eight kilos of that over here
which is a one thousand calorie drink
that you have but two thousand calorie
drink you have twice a day just like
ploughed the food otherwise was very
religious how did that manifest spend a
lot of time in the mosque
celibate didn't drink one of the kind of
I have a memory of you sir from this
period of time one of the only knows I
have we're on an art trip it would have
been like 1817 Ramadan yeah
yeah I was walking not mother we were in
the amble ambleside on our trip I went
for a pizza like 4:00 in the morning
notice there was a light on someone in a
room put put my head in Yusef sat by
himself eating a green pepper like an
apple so this is the difference between
like this the flipping between extremes
of at the time probably way to wait
under 60 kilos shredding them shreddies
Ready Brek thinking that a green pepper
is the thing to eat when you've got a
window of time to detain you and you
have a super low volume super high
volume super low cut like you couldn't
have found a vegetable with a lower
camera and then switched from that to
the other extreme so yeah very quiet
religious not didn't really know why I
was at uni or what I was doing like went
into the maths just because I thought
like and then ended up kind of on the
wrong track and not so there's some
lessons we learned from that but the I
was also very reckless with my body be
in the obviously gaining math amounts of
weight but also just training on and
through pain quite a lot so there's a
few training mistakes to get into as
well but I'm sure we'll get into that
exact do you see you didn't squat
squatting three times a week or
something for a while yeah I mean two
breathing squaws we yeah breathing
squats we I mean we've rotated through
all kinds of blackness everything every
stupid diet arms trade it seems like so
so hearing some of the common themes
between both of your guys's things what
you've got my back with his fitness so
in one form another fitness was still a
really big bit of your life when what
ten years ago if it's real eighteen
through the premenopausal so it was I
think probably both of us pre Fitness
were probably
I thought either maybe not for you I was
I was fat lacking in confidence like
1617 year at me like no female attention
no like didn't really think very much of
myself and and then fitness was my like
access into gaining self belief I think
was that same for you unless sir it was
something that I just kind of yeah I
don't think I've got is as much of luck
it a kind of rocky so yeah rocky kind of
story for that but yeah there was it was
there is definitely the common thread
that like went between extremes of just
trying mental stuff and then you know
ten years later going to join in a cult
forced submersion for two hours a day
getting banned from Jasmine pool yeah
reminders to set yourself to just eat
your big bowl of spinach like nothing's
changed
no it's very much just on maintenance
mode like it's I think having taken all
that stuff out cleared out the pipes
it's it's just on the mechanism a
khadeem it's how we all met there isn't
it Fitness in one where that's true
so we met because in school gym we met
Chris because of propane fitness we've
got been because of Harrison yeah so all
the news yeah live comes back to babble
well I mean where were you 10 years ago
Chris beside have been 21 so in the
central reservation in Spain 10 reefs
like that was 25 right there's a little
while the Far Away auntie Sheila been
finishing uni no so I did placement yeah
and then also did masters so right 85
years so I only lacked uni at 23 we met
we'd have met you
25 the years occur so what your
necessary trifle so 21 I would have been
still running college which is a big
bark role in mucus you are still safe
than my phone as Chris College leaves I
can tell the people that know me from
that era because they just call me
college
and it's the most bizarre thing to hear
someone say that now the same as people
that don't know that he's ever mastered
afro the same as people that don't know
that was on take me out or live Island
like you have these evenings of your
life yeah and people are ride in it and
especially if you do kind of what we've
done it you're in the world of online
marketing or you know like content
creation or whatever there's there are
people that have never become that
they'll be people that you have listened
to ten years ago that you don't listen
to now you know like the view guys from
like t nation or whatever like you be
able to quote that stuff inside there's
a fro like a line in the sand for you
like is that a time that I think so you
know have you have you had I don't know
if you've had anyone who you haven't
seen since pre afro and then they
approach you and speak to you as if like
as the crisp that they knew and this is
almost like a afro carnage yeah you know
easy a little bit like that this is a
phenomenon where like people put you in
a role that they remember you Kim yeah
but until they update the programming
why should they can say well yeah
they've got to extrapolate forward you
know I mean unless unless you come and
you've now got that long hair and dreads
and you covered in tattoos and you were
an elephant pants like why would they
presume that anything's changed yeah so
um so yet 21 I would have been fully
drinking the club promoter kool-aid I
would have just completed so right now
considering that we're in December I
would have just been kicked out of
Scotland by Scottish Parliament for
having our personal licenses threatened
for both me and Darren are through on
BBC Radio Parliament Scotland because
they didn't want carnage doing
multi-sites
bar crawl events in their cities so we
ran out I would have also just been hit
head-on at 60 miles an hour by a snow
plow on the a1 going up to Scotland
which hit by snow it might snow flat at
60 miles an ounce 120 mile an hour
impact that was fun it's amazing that
you were right yeah we only clipped us
but the damage was intense
every airbag deployed and all the rest
of it anyway that was that was fun but
this is when I was out intimated I was
hosting in top-top palace with my top
off three nights a week Thursday Friday
Saturday
oh yeah spurts stencil spray-paint this
is where I put you in like the Scott
Timlin and sort of medieval oh yeah it's
Scott Disneyland all that Joss Mooney
like that that all crude that was it so
that was I think probably the height of
or close to the height of that hyper
partying for me but yet again with that
like I'd started to attach a lot of my
sense of self-worth to my success within
business to my notoriety socially around
town I think going through school
I'd been less central socially with like
big groups of people and stuff and then
you get to Union it's the ultimate
chance to kind of reinvent yourself and
become someone and have a tighter social
circle and yeah I just had sort of found
my feet with that and then it becomes
like this self-perpetuating cycle of
like party more no more people become
what popular party more but no more
people become up a little bit and then
you can always justify it because it's
how well it's my job my job is to know
people the more people that know me the
more come to my events the moment he we
make so yeah that would have been that
and then rolling it forward for me there
was quite an important period between 21
and 24 which was when I started to
properly become a businessman with
regards to events run started running
weekly Saudis and anyway I think a lot
of my time again there was Fitness was
quite bothered about my training was
about to go so in six months time I
would have been going to go and do a
season in Ibiza I fell in love with a
girl out in abathur and went and had
this like crazy holiday romance thing
out there which was like a really
interesting that beautiful experience
actually like even 10 years on still
like a lovely a lovely thing to look
back on but yeah I think that was that's
kind of probably a pretty good landscape
to do that so to give it a headline
right we can get into some nuanced and
stuff in a second but you've got 30
seconds you can phone yourself 10 years
ago from now you've got
seconds or speak to them and I'm gonna
time it on here so you can have you can
have a minute to prep
I actually got asked this oh no you
didn't it's in a six minute diary it's
in a six minute diary and it's like
you've got 30 seconds so I just wrote it
out so I think I can probably afford to
go first if you want okay right show me
a time you it's I can watch out here a
glass it okay
so ring ring ring ring hello
I'm a it's Chris don't ask right you
need to stop drinking and focus on
personal development you need to learn
to focus on yourself first and not on
other people confidence comes from
within you don't know as much as you
think you do stop getting into
relationships with girls that are bad
for you no I really mean it stop getting
into relationships with girls that are
bad for you you need to spend time
around with the people you need to
travel more and you need to let go of
the feeling that you are not good enough
there you go that's 90 seconds put that
hair if you got that phone call you just
be like who like calyx throughout the
plane so the big thing the big things
for me all that the big things to take
out the headline were I kept on getting
in and out of relationships with girls
and the long-term reason for that was
because I hadn't had a lot of
relationships when I was younger I I had
a difficulty saying no this isn't right
because I deep down I don't think I felt
like I was worthy so it's like Who am I
to say to this girl that like I'm not
support like I shouldn't hurt her and I
think that that stemmed from me being
like I'm not supposed to have
relationships that wasn't what I've
grown up with this is all new to me this
is a blessing that I should be like
really happy for or whatever whatever
and then other things were I was
focusing very much so on what other
people thought of me I was bothered
about like how I was regarded by
everybody else as opposed to indulging
in my own like genuinely and my own
interests which is why I do now at this
podcast it's like I get to speak to
whoever I want and if people like it
great and if they don't then fantastic
also like I'm just bothered about what I
do is shooting all the passions that I
do now again it's mostly the same I'm
like the Holden to very few people I
don't care so that was that was
headlines to me so who wants to go up
next Johnny Yousef yeah okay right ring
ring ring ring answer hi it's me
honey I need to stop because I had it so
clearly in my head a minute go that's
not gone all right it's gone it's gone
it's gone okay well I mean this is that
there's there's no more high-pressure
phone call that you've ever got to make
isn't it if you got a call from your
future self and it was like yeah okay
thing is in its ancient paradox or
something it's like how to define your
life values and it's like you've got one
imagine you're on your deathbed and your
grandkid comes up to you and says
granddad what sir what did what sort of
single sentence of advice you give me
and you've got a minute and that's how
to define in your life what's most
important but with that in mind it comes
yourself right I used to speak ring ring
hello you so speaking that is correct
listen to me very carefully
ditch religion ditch the girlfriend
progressively overload pick a single
program do if the next ten years don't
deviate only gain maximum one kilogram
per month take a year think about what
you want to do and I had another one
spend time and dad yeah that was that
was this spend time with your parents
meditate read do it properly in the
interesting that like it's such simple
[ __ ] and it's so boring like if I got
that call from me [ __ ] you know all
right there oh yeah that will definitely
here this don't slip a disc cuz I know
what deadlift P be even if it hurts like
no that's for the rest of you like that
slipped disc is that you or not it's not
ring me and yeah it's like if I got that
phone call ten years ago
from [ __ ] boring-ass 31 year old mate
so you've been so bad how long is that
right how many birds have you banged in
that time yeah and you got rid of the
hair right well you must still at least
be lifting crossfit what what's that
exist I know right Jonathan Wright
medalist are you checking it twice
[Laughter]
ringing ringing hello
right one do 531 and track calories from
today don't deviate from that until you
stop progressing on the key let's start
start meditating from now Google it
figure out basic stuff just begin do
something do 10 minutes go to things go
to events go to things with friends even
if you think aren't a bad idea that's a
waste of time you'll remember the
experience is more than things that you
accumulate or buy take propane more
seriously sooner stop pissing around
with it learn marketing and sales
trading and coding hire a coach sooner
ask for help sooner that's far better
I wrote it down yeah that's not true
we've progressively mine was really
messy yours was kind of messy and yours
are [ __ ] gross I was thinking too
much about the fitness because I've done
a podcast already called well you say to
your 18 year old self and it was three
bits of advice just show us which is the
do five thirty one for ten years thirty
VA gasoline as possible once and then
just gave her my slowly reading about
and stay injury-free so but then but
then the other ones threw me off those
so but yeah but the summers are getting
yeah taketake propane seriously learn to
code learn to trade like yeah start
meditating hire a coach I think Jesus
like if you're 18 I'd say go an hour a
day because you've got so much time when
you're 18 you know if you don't do what
an hour a day better say now or do you
know what else I tell myself starting
uni do so I would try I'd write myself a
morning routine
that's a silhouette pretty basic [ __ ]
which would just be like read two or
three pages of something be find
interesting meditate and just do to
Pomodoro's at work like even if you do
[ __ ] all else for us today you stick to
Pomodoro that and Evernote premium why I
think ting exists at the time then I can
remember sitting in the corner of my
room at uni writing out googling are
looking up on like the Tesco website
making myself a diet plan trying to work
out macros and calories because my
fitness pal didn't exist Jesus I was
think about this pace of progress from
2019 Peter I've got a [ __ ] clue and
also like I feel like that was the
golden era and it's boring now I
remember when I thought creatine I
wasn't sure where the creatine is legal
in my heart yeah like I'm Jack 3ds to
have unfed amines in it yeah well the is
the to Pomodoro's thing as well like I'm
convinced that I've wasted 18 months of
total time between any climate yeah
between 18 and 23 I think like right
that's more macros you know in every
year you mean oh yes every is okay toss
up [ __ ] around we've heard what each
of us have so download cold turkey that
was gonna be step one this is what I
mean like so my net diary was your best
cracker tracking calories you know you
know what I should have done which would
have fixed all of these by Bitcoin if
we'd all just said hey I'm thinking of
buying this
it's called Bitcoin and I was I know it
sounds stupid
okay so buy Bitcoin by Facebook July
Amazon by Netflix or Amazon and then
dude that's your life don't bother with
you there's no point because those
actually be better than because of all
the advice we're saying now with a yes
would have got you to a better stage but
actually we wouldn't have had any of the
insight that would have generated me so
this is the problem this is one sort
psyche future for actually yeah I still
remember the conversation that we had
where it was after that when oil like
tanked and we had like maybe like 10
grand or something oil within the
business run I was like how much would
we have made if we just shorted oil with
all the money in the business at the
time and you said was like it would be
infinite single day between I can't
remember the dates but it was like
two-year run of just dark like tanning
oil I said you would have can you just
let her be on that read leveraging and
just re-entering the trade at 50 times
never you would have Jeff it's because
you ended up with a anus like yeah cuz
I've spent in a farty like it was the
time we might I think it was the Saudis
or the Q 80s that were just dumping yeah
why not caring about the price so that's
an important thing let's say that you
let's say it's someone who's you can be
any agent listening to it and thinking
ah there's a couple of tiny little
nuggets of wisdom in that flood of
that's just been put out there like
several people who just download
five-three-one who start doing it
let me save them that's made me realize
how terrible I'd be on a 30 second phone
call with myself mid-quarter key the
planet yeah what you want to do is give
advice that is access to advice rather
than the advices so bring this person's
yang to them so exact is guessing yeah
because then it you leverage the time
yeah and so some people might be
listening and [ __ ] whatever age there
might be some nuggets of wisdom or get
into them in a second but even ordering
was modern wisdom it's this is 10 years
ago wisdom it you've hit it on the head
there that without context without like
the environment to absorb these
understandings it's [ __ ] nothing like
all of it and I was gonna do a podcast
on this ages ago and I realized that it
one sentence podcast and the question
was why do realizations about our lives
take so long to sink in I can tell you
the equivalent of mate you're gonna get
hit by a car in ten years time and you
won't believe it until you get hit by
the car yeah and we are doing that
constantly riding the crest of now all
the time like I know for an absolute
fact that if I stopped doing Instagram
stop doing Twitter stop doing Facebook
and double down on podcasts and YouTube
my reach in five years time would be
bigger than if I did that and that be
happier and I'd be more productive I
know I know it for a fact
but I can't bring myself to do it until
the point comes when I have to do it
I think in five years time it'll all
just be one shot for well just search
platforms I think social stuff will be
braum it'll be one weren't it so but I
just think people are fighting it moving
away Chris is right like no one to
search base model of that yeah it's
where you that create a real following
so yeah the mask our YouTube channel
started twenty seven to ten years ago I
really don't doubt was about getting
through the YouTube channels
yeah like people's going high like live
Facebook Ads like the people who were
running Facebook ads in 2007 taking
candy from a baby so that is a good
point like hey in fact anything online
so writing a blog doing a youtube
channel like holding you know any
YouTube channel that is like has 1,000
subscribers and there's like mildly
successful now would have 100,000 but
back then if you use a decent camera
that was all you needed to to
differentiate so we can be wistfully
nostalgic about the time when we could
have been should have would have as much
as we want but I think yeah without the
context like all of the lessons that
we're talking about here can it don't
really matter
sorry and this is one of the criticisms
that I get about life hacks although I
think it's slightly different because
those are designed to be piecemeal tools
that you add into your life and they're
not lessons that are supposed to be
learned but let's try and take some of
the stuff we've had
90 seconds combined time what are some
of the things that we've tried to look
at we've said with regards to training
the principle is find a program which
forces progressive overload and stick to
it and do not do not change it for me
it's encapsulated by I think it's just
users quote which is the bad news is
there's no way to accelerate the process
the good news is there's no way to
accelerate project ironically in in us
trying so desperately to accelerate the
process you knocked it
we aren't yeah like wait and we were
vacillating with all kinds of little
because that's it mice and attempts at
optimizing stuff yeah to the point where
we actually lost sight of the can you
make sure described in 30 seconds
website as one five three one is for
people who don't know
so it's non linear periodization which
just means there is a light week meeting
we have a week D load and it focuses on
core lifts big big lifts and it's its
built-in progressive overload that can
last a very long time so if you just go
at the gym and just try and lift more
weight you'll hit mer-pup pretty quickly
if you try and hit more reps than more
weight you'll last a little bit longer
but again jirobo pretty quickly if you
just stick with five three one you start
off so light there's so much longevity
built into the way it's program it's so
simple you you also learn the nice thing
about it is so many people spend all
this time in the gym they don't really
know what it's like to approach a bar
valve and be a bit worried about it but
even that force have you been doing
terrified about it about 3:1 yeah
they're forces you into a level of
progression that you wouldn't access
through like chest and back the problem
is it's very butterfly effects because
if had a Johnny and I just done 531 from
the age of 17 and not really thought
about it and she let Fitness blend into
the background and then five years later
both be very in very good shape on
invested lifters uninjured
we wouldn't we wouldn't have generated
the insight to create a fitness website
yeah with loads of content loads and
richness of experience to be able to
create content with I also don't know
dear whether or not doing all that stuff
created results even better
that's the real because you can't we
talk about this all the time like Blair
test it oh if you could split test
yourself that would be the number one
super power bands down but you'd have to
be able to rerun it though wouldn't you
like if you could just go any split
testing that you don't get to go back so
doesn't matter if it was a B versus like
hundreds of Harilal split tests and then
you could just oh yeah
so training we've said the ethos for
whoever is listening is find a program
which has progressive overload built in
is that the key thing with 5:31 so i
think the bigger thing which is what I
was saying with you so school is
whatever you do you're gonna have to do
for a long time for it to work so pick
something that you enjoy it's not that
of a difficult thing to do I'm not
stupid
yeah so like don't try and become a yoga
master whilst also trying to become
become a Power lifter or like if you
hate the thought of going in the gym
don't pick going to the gym take up
running take up rugby take up [ __ ]
man if if going to the gym for two hours
is a massive problem for your schedule
don't do that either
like whatever think whatever I pick to
do now in it in this week is an example
I'm gonna have to do that every week for
the rest of this year trying to deal
with it can I is that possible and if
not do something else okay so that's why
we've gone with Fitness what else did we
touch on I think yours yours was [ __ ]
amazing man let me get away so but I
suppose the principle behind learn to
code learn to trade excellent don't face
because this is all stuff that only now
do we know the the impact of that having
those skills and having learned them
well started them 10 years ago so advice
to people now for them to take it's less
of a global heuristic it would be look
look ahead and say what is going to be
the skill or the the feature or whatever
that is going to be most valuable in
five years time and how can you get an
edge on that now
so I serve various as it wasn't
impossible I was like well it's under
Cortez podcaster did with him at the
start
he said if he was to give someone skills
it would be coding website copy the
ability to sell and like speaking so
ability to be on podcasts to speak live
to have to communicate yeah so the last
three I think would be useful but what
we don't know is is the future of coding
actually going to become less valuable
as because coding has a skill becomes
less code intensive and easier as time
goes on because the tools are with it
you code with become more and more
complex and have larger building blocks
to be able to put things together about
making a website you need to know HTML
your 10 years ago but once yeah so it so
actually it's useless to know HTML now
if you have to make a website because
even if you were to hand code it in HTML
you your gnome is going to because
they're not before they or 10 years ago
you teaching the guy who created Wix
yeah yeah so you have to be what what a
second or third level you know the
hardest thing about all this is is that
right now we're in the position that
we're speaking to because there are ten
in ten years ourselves will be saying
the same thing and you just told you you
just gave yourself the advice you needed
well a lot of its give up on social and
focus on its weight pulling the pin it's
not just about telling me advice isn't
it's [ __ ] doing it yeah like you know
you know like have known fine well what
would probably have been optimal with
your training or with your your diet or
whatever and another thing we have to
consider it's all one good going are
just stick to five three one for ten
years but it's like yeah all right me
I'm not a robot i'm not i need to have
variety of fun yeah and we're not
utilitarian [ __ ] machines here like i
want to have variety but do you want
variety more than you want results it's
yet do you want entertainment by the
process or the progress yeah it's it's
just something that i went within an
email where we do split up with
girlfriends [ __ ] hell man I mean this
wasn't one for you but Jesus Christ it
wasn't for me oh [ __ ] yeah that wasn't
why I wasn't one for me
wasn't one for you yeah
because he was single uh did you like
him I've just broken up with a
girlfriend at the time
but I did definitely spend too long in
relationships and I should have enough
sooner why did I stay I just needed
somebody to sit down and explain box a
box B to me put it if someone had done
that I think it would have been like the
clouds part of em but not right I can't
open look at it you can't open that loop
without closing it but it's a complex
thing so just don't don't stay in a
situation that's bad and expect it to
get better some cost yeah so that's this
I did that with my job I did that with
relationships I did that with some
friendships I did that with injuries and
training programs like so many things
you think like this is a problem I'm
experiencing discomfort from this but
it's alright it'll get better be better
next week it'll fix itself
I mean it's kind of obvious it's a bit
glib to say this but all of our 32nd
calls are is three things to stop his
three things to start yeah go yeah yes I
mean what else is there well you can
only start or stop thing things or keep
going
I suppose it's with you what you just
said before the box a thing is like when
you're in a winning scenario absolutely
double down on that
so rather than on cast platform yeah
yeah what you were saying about as
intense you did wheezing pull them loads
of different directions those may I
think was it right so like rather than
thinking I was what you're saying I
think got a previous episode like you're
doing a veins the costs are we gonna do
like if you find something that you're
doing and anything in life like a skill
that you really good at or a sport that
you really good at or like your wallet
whatever just absolutely hammer down on
that so I mean this is again it's if I
was to predict the advice in fact let's
do that after this let's predict the
advice that I attend yourself from now
we'll give ourselves it's so great that
this will hopefully still be Internet
well unless unless of course it's
post-apocalyptic death world yeah and
we're all Mad Max the great level ones
the Russians the Russians yeah it is
you'll be fine though oh yeah yeah well
you can just go back to Egypt um yeah
so yeah I think if you will get a four
week it's not even a racist term it's
like it's like a childish insole isn't
it yeah yeah okay so we've got some
stuff about relationships that we've
we've doubled down on things that we've
stuck in things that were losing trades
essentially we just let them run hmm I
was talking to Chris sparks yesterday
productivity expert poker guy and he
lives on risk right top 20 poker players
on the planet
he lives risk for a living that's his
job to work out how much risk ease it
manages it and eaters and what he said
was his end of year review everything is
up for sale I was like what do you mean
by that and he said nothing gets
grandfathered in from year to year
nothing not that is cool yeah so
everything has to in it's right yeah and
he says he has two choices with
everything that's in his life you write
it down yeah because I'll just send him
our Chris yeah sorry Chris if you
listening mate I didn't have to keep
permission I'm sure you'll be fine with
it so what he says is as he ends the
year and this is such a clever heuristic
man oh my god
as he ends each year he has looks at all
of the different things that he's doing
with his life relationships friendships
business hobbies passions etc and he has
two choices one of them is double the
amount of time that he's invested on it
and the other one he's get rid so
practically you have to cut then you
have to cut 50% of everything you didn't
write well actually no sorry you don't
have to cut 50% of everything that
you're doing because you could get rid
of a load of little things right okay
you could actually cut 90% of the stuff
that you're doing and it's still only be
50% only 10% of the stuff that you're
doing in your name yeah
yeah but it's the idea of always be
always be questioning everything that
you doing always always be narrowing
always been itching harder into what you
are good at till this is one question
one thing it's terrifying yeah cuz if
the first part you're like oh that's
hope and then most like right double
more quick you like and that's that's
the word that Annie thinks about it from
a player's perspective right like every
single year at the end of every year
this is gonna go out probably just
shortly into the new year like so every
habit every relationship everything I do
you have time to choose where you're
going to double down on it are you gonna
get rid of it
and I think it's it's scary but it's the
way it is it's precisely the way that
everyone that we know is the best in the
world at what they do we don't know
anyone like polymaths
of [ __ ] New Age media do not exist
like this Gary Vee is as close as you're
gonna get but he's still one thing he
still does produce content mostly video
and audio I see him as Instagram to be
honest repurpose around different
platforms like there's no one you know
James clear just double down on habits
just become the best on the planet he's
been he's actually big on like he
credits his business growth to just
wrote two articles a week like one of
his habits was writing who's like I'm
just gonna write two excellent articles
every time we see what we did for three
four years there was oil excellent we
stopped them were they all excellent
they were they were all yeah article we
put a lot of time into that really yeah
wow so yeah I mean that's as something
that you can try and take away and I
will be trying to as well if you have
something in your life or you know a lot
of things in your life if you feel like
you're spending a lot of different
plates question why they're there and
think about I got like ah what is it
therefore is it there because it's
grandfathered in because it's already
got a seat at the table or does it
actually deserve to eat if it doesn't
deserve to eat then like it can make a
room for someone that does
we're all a bit stunned by that double
down which makes you think doesn't it
and it just and the thing would you said
about like what you just said about how
because people follow like this is very
business yes birds but people follow
like good writers good podcasters people
are really influential and Instagram
people are great on LinkedIn Twitter and
then I write well I do all of those
things but none of those people are
worrying about anything other than that
thing that think yeah and that's why
they're that so the problem is spreading
yourself too thin is if you have a
hundred units of talent and you spread
it across ten things even if you are
absolutely maxing out within each of
those areas you can only become as good
as the 10 out of 100 the person that's
in that category where you'll just be
beaten by a person who's doing one less
platform than you or one less thing than
you and you'll be annihilated by the
person he was doing one of those
platform he's got out competed by
someone who's prepared to go all in
yes something yeah but by that same
token because we don't have the benefit
of [ __ ] divinity moving forward we
also want to hedge we're also as they're
not purely utilitarian being so it means
that we want to have different things
going on so that we have variety that
keeps us feeling alive that keeps us
having this diet of different things
that make us feel interested and stuff
like that and different things serve
different purposes as well then they're
like it's not like there's no such thing
and anything that is a that is a
catch-all this is the one solution this
is the best thing like there's no best
training methodology there's no best
diet approach there's no best recovery
method but it's about like picking the
most effective for you isn't it true
like you to pick the optimum blend for
the person that you want to be like
because going 10/10 Xing down on the one
thing means that you become by
definition a one-dimensional person and
if that's the goal that you're looking
for in the person you want to be in ten
years time then I say it but yeah
otherwise it's it's like but I mean the
principle still applies because you then
you still cut out or double
the things that you do care about but
you just pick that mixture yourself and
say write us that's the formula I still
think is well that a lot of a lot of
what most people will have the problem
it is a problem of abundance not
scarcity yeah the problem is that
they're trying to do too many things not
that they're trying to do - whew - well
too many choices isn't it it's not like
I know what to do you know that sorry
they have what I can lack of T for you -
well problems yeah no no no one ok so I
mean that's we're all kind of a little
bit shook after this [ __ ] bake based
on that what is one thing that you know
that you should be doing but aren't know
that's probably the wrong question to
ask I think why because I am doing all
of them it's what things you should I
get rid of is it not is there not
something that you're thinking like I
really should be like if you were to
give yourself advice you know I really
should be doing this more or I really I
should be putting more focus on this
doing it more is the owner to like doing
it all right yeah yeah I was that's
adding that put in another [ __ ]
Caesar where where's that your focus be
based on was asked coach like should I
do you think I should learn to code mmm
because that's something I'm not doing
at all now and he said no probably not
because it's not it's not good you like
it's such a big learning curve and it's
not a good use of your existing skill
set mm-hm just pay someone to code and
do the things that you do best one of
the things that's interesting I guess as
you get older is that the groove that
you have greased is increasingly
difficult to get out of it's like okay I
have this amount of time and the
opportunity cost of spinning back around
starting to go and go that okay I'll
coat I'll start coding now it's like
well hang on you have all of these
skills all this experience all this room
now and all of this platform whatever
whatever it might be that you have and
you're going to choose to no longer
leverage any of that so there has to be
this acceptance of like look where am I
now what is the position I am in right
now and what are the skills that are
moving forward I think all of the things
that we've chosen that we've said
like already leverage on stuff that we
do so for me it was like look stop
thinking about what other people think
that would have made me a better club
promoter I already was a club promoter
um focus on yourself and indulging in
the things that you genuinely care about
that that was something that was
massively lacking in so that was getting
rid of something I didn't need it so why
is an extra skill you can bolt on that
word just nullify all the previous
experience that you've got so in
learning to code I think if you have the
skill of selling and then you add
learning to code on top of that then
you've got a combination that most
salesmen or coders don't have the
opposite of and I think the people that
do best at the moment like if big tech
companies because they can sell and code
they can build something in there and
market it match it to the market and
sell it whereas a lot of good coders
don't think about front end or user
experience or code or or run sales and
they're just focused on like the product
and end up having this gap or they
create something that the pocket doesn't
need mm so actually marrying those two
skills would work really well but it's
trying to find the what's easier
teaching a Salesman to code or coded to
sail to the to country things aren't
they this over I would not just up why
don't you just get marketing specialist
yes that or you could say the same thing
about why don't you get a coder well
yeah yeah like you don't need to be draw
then learn to sell and pay some of the
code or learn to code and paste want to
sell be the person who can sell will be
able to deal with the world once codings
just automated so I spoke to Benjamin
Dennehy the UK's most hated sales
training yesterday for a Kiwi guy and he
was like when the cockroaches ruled the
earth and the atomic bombs have all gone
off it was like people still need me
yeah you still be yourself it's not need
to sell the atomic bombs yeah yeah it's
it's finding so like the in all the the
platform questions like the thing that
remains in all of it is email so the
thing that I in Netflix John Lewis by
Amazon all these companies send email
emails Lindy isn't it for Lindy yeah it
is
I don't know that it what okay so Lindy
the Lindy effect is a metal model which
describes the degradation of
non-perishable goods and services I
think it's just like items essentially
so for instance nineteen eighty-four is
a Lindy book it's been around for five
years four words therefore you can
presume it's gonna be around for at
least thirty five more right so tonic
Abbott's has been around for one year
despite the fact that all right okay
like our emails Lindy like emails being
around for the ages though it's likely
to be around so there's a graphic that's
like going around the internet at the
moment of like things that happen
permanently tonight we've seen it no so
he's nice at the tap but yeah like per
minute so like the number of snapchat
sent the number of its are they okay and
like everyone expects by card will be
like YouTube minutes whatsoever but it's
like email like dicks on all like them
number of emails sent per minute on the
internet is astronomical but there are
people who are like oh is actually
believe our email doesn't work I need me
on social media but then like people
would not send emails if it's we're not
reading them like it would be the most
asinine waste of time like everybody at
work is email sending emails so I yeah
so I see whenever we're talking about
that sort of thing that we're don't put
their attention inside well it's only
got an email list as long as you're
emailing if you decide the Twitter's the
thing you just send the table to tell
all your emails about it so like there's
a I think often in every area of your
life sorry there's a there's an email
marketing version so it's like right I
want to work on my like spirituality
like is it reading is it like yoga or is
it just 20 minutes meditation every day
place the email marketing that u s--
approached to me I think probably the
the meditation 20 minutes meditation if
I'm not doing that then I've got no
business like reading a self-development
book yeah she said I mean it's the same
thing I've lost you say it's just a hub
in smoke spoke model so it's like the
hub in the middle the thing which is
going to be there for the longest is
email and then everything else is just
extra meais [ __ ] like okay billion
so still adds to the picture but is I'm
building a business
I'm working really really hard on my
Instagram it's a look at how long's
Instagram I'm gonna be around for how
many people have you gotten your insta I
got 200,000 how many people getting your
email list I've got 2,000 right okay
well what happens when Instagram [ __ ]
off cuz he hasn't
yeah okay so it's just in terms of
allocating your attention so it's like
with fitness and nutrition like are you
aware of your calorie intake right
whatever lifts not like don't worry
about supplementation like don't worry
about in calories all week in a matter
are you progressively overloading in
something and then don't worry about
cross are you really all in the
marketing yes no if no go back to is it
are you doing in my mother it's this way
to see it it's like if you and I are
starting like a ticktick channel yeah
and I have an email list so hundred
thousand people and you have zero who
was going to win at the game of growing
a tick tick what it is always at channel
tick tock tick tick sea mailers dealer
SERPs at that I knew that I said
something wrong like straw version of
music sorry
tick tick what we use is a task
management Pomodoro integrate yeah okay
so we've got we got about 10 minutes
left
um we've spoken about the fact that
sticking to the program is a good idea
we've spoken about the fact that doing
less better or doing less more
essentially is a pretty good heuristic
to use young relationships should be let
go of more freely than you think at the
time they just probably won't matter as
much as you think that it seems pretty
obvious looking back to how many people
do you know that get together during
freshers week at uni and then state like
they do exist but like this is a throw
it out to you missing it's a full open a
lot of people that I know who like being
in relationships a long time since we're
like 17 16 tend to have some kind of
turbulence and their relationship
because they haven't had the freedom
and smoke there are obviously examples
of that not being the case what Darren
Kelly people to get their entire lives
business partners and his missus got
together and like I think second year of
you knees like halfway through the
second year uni and they're like the
[ __ ] British version of the American
Dream white-picket-fence two dogs two
kids I mean amazing but the problem is
they are the problem they are precisely
the problem because they give hope to
the 19 year old you think that's the
model that this is what's going to
happen so you Darren at the issue okay
and it's like trying to it's like saying
like oh well alan shearer just played
loads of football so that's what I'm
gonna do because that'll work for me
yeah okay so I you're not quite luck by
survivorship bias yeah yeah what else
have you got on your phone Joanie what
else was in that list that we you
basically did the list for a street leak
actual thing that I added at the end
that covers everything is ask for help
does that get coach yeah well so as do
you fight we won't stop meditating so
deep like you so don't when you do
things go to events that almost always a
good idea so like there's so many things
that I'm like I shouldn't do this I
should go to that I won't go at that
part you're working that person for a
coffee
it'll be shite you go and cement awesome
yeah say yes to more adventures yeah
saying the trouble without you you can I
imagine get into some deeper water quite
quickly where just say yes yeah you have
you ever been even close to that
no but that's coming from a that's
coming from someone who'd probably err
on the side of like that seems like
about out of your version yeah always if
you like I'll go to everything and you
start going to more I know more people
that are on and this might just be like
my sphere of awareness bias but I know
more people that are towards our side
which is say need to say yes to less in
terms of business and projects and need
to say yes to more in terms of
experience in adventure yep yep yeah
smart taking business more seriously
sooner I thought good even finer but I
would have been [ __ ] terrible for me
I'd already like completely linchpin my
sense of identity to the success of the
business right like if we had a bad
night at work I was a bad person if we
had a good night at work I was worthy
right okay so doubling down on that
would have would have been it would have
been me the
a piece of advice would have been too
upset um
you are not your accomplishments is that
what you almost merged your social life
with you with your sense of missus
business progress as well like whenever
you went to a party whenever you were
like sama messy yeah so hard to not be
the case when like probably everyone's
at everyone else's social life is your
work life at uni stick by and you are
the party guy
it's the inversion of what it's still
now if I speak to someone hey man I like
what you up to this weekend like you
fancy meeting up or whatever it's like
oh yeah like let's go on a night out
it's like no like that's what I do for
work I know it's more than you do for
fun
but what you do for fun I do for work
just for swinging that's not that but
for them it's the novelty to sentence if
I can see on a day it's like if you've
spent your entire day with your podcast
with a porn star if you've spent your
entire day getting DP'd of a huge
Amsterdam man our friend and his friend
like and you come home and your
partner's like oh hi darling how are you
got my friend round here he just the
fancies a bit ever go on you yeah that
might be her idea
the best evening ever fear true sir she
really does she's it go the best thing
about that podcast on YouTube is that
the frame that she's in you're also in
when she's talking about the most like
vivid stuff that you're just like yeah
so started taking business more
seriously the thing is I don't again
looking back like had we done that I
might have wrecked it because I think
probably this part of the fact that we
were just doing because we just
absolutely love doing mother was
emergent like yeah that's what got the
organic inquiries it was the fact that
it was just putting out content yeah
because they were just interested and
it's what we tell our business clients
now isn't it it's like make content
first don't just go be the weird uncle
at the barbecue that tries to sell
straight away give first start a fashion
they just like the Google game takes a
long time we were ranked first page of
Google and gang and Granick inquiries
for
coaching clients from just like a
standard Ramadan WordPress template
though we were just bashing out because
the use of pro articles like literally
seven or eight years ago that are still
like your drive isn't over yet
yeah that's why I think weird search
based stuff like and it'll be the same
for YouTube Lindy but you have I imagine
they'll be episodes modern Muslim that
are still taken over daily we don't have
stuff that surges virally there is like
ten episodes on YouTube that just just
do five K day yes between them all yeah
it just sits at that and that's now the
new basis so that's the thing like
compare that to Instagram imagine if you
try to get 5,000 views a day on
Instagram the work required for that
every day was YouTube just like
translates the lazy river the internet
it's brilliant learn marketing and sales
were covered that learn trade then the
code and ask for help ask for help
things a big gone man
like especially when you're that age
when you young like I think you you
resist I see any resisted like I didn't
hire my first fitness coach which is
mental till like 23 was yeah yeah so I
tried for ages on my own I struggled on
my own I wouldn't have a 18 I would have
been like what are these guys yeah like
we had hours and hours of conversations
trying to figure out like is it alright
to have two high-carb days or yeah yeah
there's so much so one of the most the
highest performing things we ever did
was got John Keifer on the podcast right
before carb backloading was released
that hadn't there was no thought in that
other than we just need to understand
whether it's alright to have fat in your
back load or whether it has to be just
carved yeah and that was why you asked
him for podcast we have some on the
podcast then I went on his podcast and
that was all just out of like
desperation of like John how is incident
work please like I remember you don't
have carbs during the day you have just
fun protein and then 5 p.m. KFC bargain
buckets which is mostly flat dominant
anyway and certainly from a calorie
perspective and then and then a drink
that was 100 grams of dextrose a hundred
and fifty
of caffeine your fire yeah yeah yeah
5:00 p.m. Lucy because it like blood for
something yeah caffeine was shuttling it
yeah exactly yeah leucine hydrolyzed
whey like the most all the most
disgusting powders just put into one
thing and you just plug it down try and
like hold your nose and make sure you
don't vomit for the next couple of
minutes anyway what I really miss about
that though was that it was it was
exciting his [ __ ] wasn't it like I
remember new frontier yeah I remember
like it was 6:00 a.m. and we were
skyping with John Kiefer for our podcast
and like being just beside myself with
excitement about it and like doing the
program like that yeah yeah
after having like 500 grams of sugar
just trained I remember having my
carbonyl coding protocol in high so I
remember you text me saying can I have
who's a picture of birthday cakes and
can I have birthday cake for carb
backloading I was like why did you have
birthday cake why do I birthday cake and
your reply was just said it says on it
party and I like to party I remember
used to eat um tins of chicken wire
chunky chicken yes delete it that's
really backup stuff desperate yeah yeah
food like Chucky chicken with rice good
meal and you I remember your reasoning
for carb backloading was it was a reason
that you had to go the gym because if he
didn't train couldn't he cannot ops yeah
so I was like burger and cheese or an
egg the way they do it um how guys
calories alright we're coming to the end
what are some of the things that you've
realized during this conversation you
know that wherever you are giving people
the most advice is probably where you
need the advice the most that's
something I hear a lot at the moment
also bike I think the stuff that you all
this stuff that we've just said is all
advice that we all need right now and
like if you think about all the stuff
you tell your friends all the advice
you're giving the people that look at
that
area of your life yourself it's probably
the area that you talk loads about we
don't actually do much in well fantastic
if talking a good game
yeah and of giving people advice that we
wholeheartedly require ourselves exactly
what about you surf anything any little
gems come out of this one is short oil
yeah sure
well like all of the things they're like
we've gone general and specific and
actually all that advice does apply for
the next ten years - yeah if anything is
such a useful exercise that I've been
we've all been tricked and we in a
giving us a what is the advice we need
now yeah what would you give what advice
do you give yourself now it should have
been the title of the pilot on there
there it is there is but we'd have said
the wrong [ __ ] there we would have done
you as we've said the right stuff now
yeah goodness for that
pine thoughts I think definitely you
know Chris sparks this conversation I
had with him yesterday that [ __ ]
like singing nothing gets grandfathered
into your life just because it's already
there
relationships business projects passions
everything and at the end of each year
everything's up to sale nothing gets a
seat at the table has to earn its place
to eat and you either get to double down
on it or it gets kicked out like if you
even managed to do 10% of that heuristic
each year like [ __ ] you know there was a
when I was in the throes of fitness
obsession there was a photo that Martin
Burke on uploaded on a Facebook with a
glass of white like it's shredded glass
of wine and the photo just said don't
take this fitness stuff too seriously
like the good times roll and that you
then got had a bit of a breakdown in it
and it wasn't the affair very much I
think sometimes though like probably a
bit of advice I would have also should
have had 10 years ago is like it's
alright to not like have all the answers
be exactly where you think you need to
be be making progress all the time that
you can't just
have a good have good fun don't take it
to Syria
let the good times roll that is a great
passing thought
yeah thanks to Martin hasn't it always
remember that Martin Burke and is and
has always been right about everything
seriously
yeah in Fitness okay every time we
question something will think that
always a bit off on there then like we
get a little idea of our own might later
we realized Martin's right the entire
time yeah I mean it's gonna hurt it is
gonna hurt if we look back at this in
ten years time and all of the things
that we've said it just like but that's
the motivation and not let that happen
that is the motivation isn't it it's
trying to foresee what what should I be
and the question that we're asking is
what should I spend my time doing mmm
you have a limited time on this planet
right like very few minutes how do I
make the most of them and the first
thing I know that if Chris sparks was
here he would say the first thing that
you need to do is work out what you want
if you don't know what you want you are
actually flying in the dark you're
actually you're just going well what
like why should I do this because it
gets me closer to end goal and if you
don't know what and goal is what the
[ __ ] you do so yeah anyway there may be
some things that you want to discuss you
know where I'm at Chris relax on all
social media or leave questions in the
comments below
let's have a discussion about it these
guys are up in fitness and what's the
business 1 propene fitness calm /a
modern wisdom free son step look to be
honest to get some free things we reveal
like one thing that you would never
believe on length of use of speakers
it's it's a secret and I'll leave it I
can't tell you that you just will have
to go a lot your email yeah well thank
you very much for tuning in like share
and subscribe really appreciate you for
dropping by okay
why don't you buy them
[Music]
you